boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are still on site at Indy BIOS demo day
number eight we are now going to be
talking to Helen Chen hello hi thank you
for having me on your show thank you so
much for coming on really excited to
talk to you CEO of guided clarity yes
okay and you just did a talk on the main
stage what was it about well it's about
developing this new medical food for
functional aging and the idea came from
studying the mitochondria which we all
have tons of those in our nurse body I
mean but as we get older some of these
mitochondria can get dysfunctional and
starts bringing out toxic material
causing aging and health decline okay
and okay so mitochondria is in all of
ourselves of course and we don't just
have one or two of those we have like a
hundreds of thousands of a per cell
hundreds of thousands yes like for
example your heart cell needs about
5,000 mitochondria in each cell to help
you pump your blood 24/7 yes yes yeah
okay thousands per cell thousands per
cell not hundreds of thousands per cell
hundreds hundreds up to thousands per
cell yeah okay that's a lot of
mitochondria per cell okay some of them
are really functioning well and some
become dysfunctional over I mean just
like batteries I mean after a while
something gets leaky and you there's a
recycling program within ourself yeah
which is great but when we get older
it's a serious job as well so what we
have done is we did some screening we
found this molecule from mothers milk
and that can help with this decluttering
process of dysfunctional mitochondria
Wow okay all right so okay so
mitochondria is giving ourselves energy
exactly so that's why it keeps up with
your metabolism and they keep us
standing up straight yeah so those
mitochondria taking glucose as its power
all right so it does take Lucas and then
transfer eventually it's like a
production line and he will give you ATP
which is a cellular energy okay Andy
okay
than the ATP powers like protein-protein
creation pretty much all your bodily
function and they say the single biggest
determinant of how long you will live
you know after you're 60 or 70 its your
gait speed whether how fast you can walk
from one room to the next
yeah gait speed okay yeah that's well
gee I yeah okay yeah because you need so
much energy just to be able to walk
across you know how like older people
they start to shuffle and and it's also
about that coordination so your brain
takes the most energy 20% of all your
energy goes into your brain and so if
the energy is kind of yeah then you
start not being able to coordinate you
lose balance and we get older and you
fall you break your hip and that starts
kind of like the downfall whoa okay so
then are we potentially able to say that
things like when we slow down with our
gait speed walking across the room that
that is potentially one of the things
involved is this dysfunctional
mitochondria yes one of the factors and
and and this is one of the important
factors that you think that you can
potentially tackle to help us increase
our longevity well how the span is yeah
that is that is the key because I think
longevity is one thing right you live
until 100 but you want to be functional
okay yeah and so by having these better
batteries battery battery cycling
program then we can have more energy
the first area that we're targeting is a
simplest joint pain which affects
one-third of adults and after wow it's
really preventing active lifestyle
okay joint pain affects one-third of
active adults yes oh wow
so then easy turned out to be like
osteoarthritis is first start with joint
pain and a lot of athletes actually I'll
have a lot of joint pain because they're
always pounding yes yes yes exactly and
then so as we get older turns into
osteoarthritis is cutting too
kind of stiff now you're thinking about
it we're all getting some from all this
and this there's something yeah yeah and
then we don't recover as fast from
injuries and and we have more aches and
pain that's all about inflammation and a
lot of the come from dysfunctional
mitochondria they just spell out these
factors which is not good for your
health okay and now let's talk about
this breast milk so the mother's breast
milk is where you found yes this is a
molecule that's most abundant protein in
mother's milk but very low amount in
cow's milk and so what happens when a
baby what's a protein yes yes it's alpha
lacto boomin al-falaq to abuse yes it's
so long that that's why I just say lb
but it's okay and yeah left yeah okay
because it's Ella so that's a little bit
faster and so the full protein if it is
combined with the fatty acid it has
anti-cancer effect and what we have
found is one is being digested in the
gut into small peptides little bits and
then I can wrap around a milk mineral
and then it can activate this company
cluttering process a lot of times we
don't know mother's milk is more than
just nutrients it's actually helping you
have better immune function and eye
cancer and also to help you reduce
inflammation so these are a good
goodness from mothers milk so we should
potentially be supplementing ourselves
with mother's milk throughout our whole
lives
it's not really possible there's a small
amount in cassimy that's what we're
trying to do a small amount in cow's
milk yes so that's what yeah why can't
we synthesize the same that's in mothers
we can synthesize that Oh everybody sees
you just take from Cosmo Cosmo yeah but
it just takes a longer time to just
isolate that and get enough amount
because you know when a baby drinks
Mother's Milk you know the baby doesn't
have anything else in the stomach it's
just milk right you chops the right way
and so be
your enzyme I know what the same as when
you're a baby right so you need to chop
it up and your right length and you to
get to with the right mineral which if
you're eating a whole bunch of other
stuff that's gonna be helpful so that's
why we're creating this medical food
okay and then so then you're taking a
leaf from house no yes and then we chop
it up chop it up meaning you separate
okay so so we use enzyme use and enzyme
to chop it up yeah to chop it up and
then make it easier oh so it's predigest
there's predigested free digesta for you
adding the right minerals that you would
see so these are the things that we are
kind of recreating what's happening in
the baby's gut so you don't need to do
it anyway
okay you know how when we get older our
digestion it's not it's good right and
so we are trying to do this everything
pre pre digestive for people who really
need it and then I am supplementing
myself with you with you is this like
within a pill you can begin a pill form
or in Canaan powder and dissolve it in
water yeah because a lot of the older
population they can't take pills that
well and so they can you can dissolve in
water but for the people who are younger
who want to take it then of course a
pill long ago it's faster and like one a
day - a day - a day
Wow okay and then is this recommended
for people with joint pain or is this
recommend even preventative it can be
for preventative but of course I think
the first thing for as a scientist
really is to look for a target
population who have like joint pain or
people who have COPD chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease their lung
inflammation that's kind of like a real
big problem and their mitochondria
really dysfunctional they are not
breathing the right way and so we are
engaging Texas A&M instead of aging -
looking to how our product and help with
these people with COPD which is the
fourth leading cause of death
in the US see OPD yeah is the fourth
leading cause of yes yes go ahead one
more time do the acronym stands for yeah
it's chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease well and and the COPD does what
in the body again
so COPD is like you usually is people
who smoke or have been exposed to a lot
of environmental pollution and then so
they cannot usually they they can
breathe too much and then you start
seeing them with oxygen tanks and what
I'm really most worried is our troops
that have gone overseas to the Middle
East and they get exposed to let's say
gunpowder
you know there's laced with toxins I
mean explosives and also others fine
dust in these deserts and and on these
bases I mean they they get burned their
own trash I mean none of these tragedies
being hauled away you know miraculously
so when you burn trash on the base you
smell a lot of these inhale so much
toxin and we're also concerned about
people who are doing the each cigarettes
nowadays or marijuana just because I
mean you're smoking with a no filter so
these can things our lungs are very
sensitive and once they start to be
chronically inflamed and the mark
Andreea especially in the lung linings
of not working well it's not reversible
and so these also just become like kind
of chronic fatigue these people cannot
go out so that's more on the serious
side right and then what joint pain is
more just like okay I can't be as active
as I used to be but then we have people
who are really active and they are
killing it we're going for a marathon or
do their hard training and they want to
use that just wear a faster recovery
because when you go out and do really
hard training your mitochondria needs a
little boost - so it's just a faster
recycling program and then how does the
what we find in the mother's breast milk
how do we then how does that then
interact with the dysfunctional
mitochondrial yes so basically it goes
into the mitochondria so if your
mitochondria is pretty health it's kind
of like it
test nothing happens it's like yeah
you're not just a little thing you're
here just busts it off but if the
mitochondria is not very functional it
sends a signal to the nucleus and say
hey you know excuse me
we're not functional so you kind of
trigger a signal to have this
decluttering process you ala triggers
the nucleus to tell to do what with the
dysfunctional matter so basics are
hauling away so that way you haul it
away yeah so you break it down hey are
you bringing yeah you break it down so
these are your holloway you break it
down and recycle I mean it's amazing
it's interesting so it's like a city
they do a whole bunch of stuff and then
so basically you want to have all these
signals working properly but it just as
we could odor it gets everything gets a
little bit sluggish my tablet is a
little sluggish signaling is a little
sluggish so this is just a like a little
little boost and goes through the
mitochondria and matter comes it up I
owe ya you know we haven't you know
haven't be functional since its signal
to the nucleus hey call us away and he
gets all away and broken down so you can
have new mitochondria and then so am I
then able to visit the website and
already purchased not yet so we will be
launch ready in eighteen months we're
doing clinical studies right now yeah we
need to do two clinical study first and
we need to you're saying they're already
exploring we we have a small tiny what
kind of manufacturing that we're
producing message yeah putting a small
scale and people are able it's kind of
like report how they feel to you
subjectively and that's already yes so
that's so we have to informal studies
but most important these are for the
clinical trial that's yeah that's coming
up you okay your you have a lined up
clinical trial ready yes so we have two
clinical studies that's lined up we want
to do that and we also need to be able
to produce a large scale yes yes and so
in about six months we'll transition to
a pilot plant and
then to the full plant okay who's that
Wow so where where else can we find
within the evolution with these really
interesting little like nuggets that can
increase our vitality health well I
personally think I mean I studied cancer
biology for the longest time and I was
always fascinated at the beginning of
life like during embryogenesis what's
happening as ourselves transform I mean
we all came from single cells and and
eventually we divide and grow and we we
have so there's so many molecules within
us that has a potential to heal and
that's why people using stem cells you
know during embryogenesis a lot of stem
cells that has a transformative
properties and they're also signals
withing embryos that are meant to help
us to shape us the right way so these
are just long-term goals and will
continue to looking at that how we can
see things from the beginning of life
that can help us when we're getting
older so we can repair ourselves better
be more help healthy yeah yeah it's cool
the same way that we went from a single
cell to these massive creatures with so
many cells is kind of similar to how the
evolution on the planet started with
just single-celled organisms and now
there's a yeah and I think the power
using some of these natural molecules is
that you are less likely to have a toxic
side effects because especially it's
from the melian if you use something
from him I don't wanna say like mushroom
or something like somewhere like
organism a deep sea our body can can
create an immune response because never
seen it before but our body has been
genetically evolutionarily designed
drink to 1/2 certain molecules now we're
just bring these molecules back yeah
help us to clean ourselves a little bit
how this is a conversation I'm really
I'm excited to hear you building this
this is thank you thank you for teaching
us about it
yeah let's see where this can go with
healing yeah I'm excited and I
in medical food is a new discipline
because we have therapeutics which have
been in that field for 15 years and
therapeutics takes 10-15 years and and
it's really about diseases and medical
food is kind of in between is more about
something about also about preventive I
mean you mentioned about can we take
that before he gets too late right and
we also want something that's just more
complementary and you don't have to
think so much about side effects because
it's just taken from milk so I think
there's a tremendous growth in as you
can see from Indy bio our cohort very
creative very innovative way to look at
how we can innovate from food for
something natural and bring better
health for the planet and for human yes
yes how long this has been such a
pleasure thank you for joining us on the
show well thank you so much we
appreciate it thanks everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
let us know what you're thinking about
the episode also share more content like
this to your friends your families
co-workers people online oh so she made
to get talking more about things like
this and also check out the links in the
bio below to guided clarity also to
indie bio check out those links below
and also check out the links below to
simulation as well support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that you believe in build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we'll see you soon thanks
for tuning in peace